of many outstanding performances by
actors and leading roles in this year of
brilliant movies the five nominees are
for his multi-layered portrayal of the
unemployed actor who becomes a better
man by putting on a dress and gaining an
insight into the world of women Dustin
Hoffman and took see
most remarkable recreation of the young
Indian lawyer as he moved through
history to become a symbol of peace and
non-violence Ben Kingsley and Gandhi
for a searing portrait of a tortured
American father battling a sinister
system in search of his son Jack lemon
and missing
or is deep conviction as an alcoholic
lawyer who comes to victorious terms of
himself Paul Newman and the verdict
for his flamboyant caricature of a
swashbuckling film star who invades
television with a lunge and a thrust
peter o'toole in my favorite year
five outstanding performances and the
winner is Ben Kingsley and on
ladies and gentlemen members of the
Academy you have bereft me of all words
but that's not good enough
I am custodian of this award for a lot
of people let me say before continuing
any further that I was overwhelmed to be
mentioned in the same breath as the
other four gentlemen who were nominated
with me
this film was dedicated to Pandit Nehru
Lord Mountbatten of Burma I'm moti Lal
Qatari all men of great vision and
courage it was made by my friend Sir
Richard Attenborough another great man
of vision and courage and for all the
men and women who worked on the phone
this is an Oscar for vision for courage
and for acting and for peace thank you